good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Jade unfortunately research and Miller
is still not back from whatever he is
doing as it's classified let's just move
on to today's lecture shall we the place
we're going to be looking at today is
SCP 1836 object class Euclid special
containment procedures a CP 1836 is to
be rican tained within site 641 which is
disguised as an active ecological
research station and wildlife preserve
at these are coordinates if they mean
anything to you
I'll read north 74 point 13 - West 93
point eighty one I don't know
encompassing the entirety of the coming
of Inlet the research station is to be
staffed with a full-time research team
and support staff including a
classically trained angler cook I
apologize for the pronunciation I am not
familiar with that word at all and a
certified cosmetologist a 50 kilometer
radius of protected waters is to be
maintained around the site these waters
are to be patrolled by armed foundation
assets disguised as research personnel
or environmental activists elements
trespassers are to be interrogated
administered level C amnestics and
released in the nearest settlement an
access causeway is to be maintained into
one of the caves that perforate SCP 1836
access to the causeway is restricted to
the site director on-site shaman and
cosmetologist
additional personnel may be permitted by
majority consensus of the personnel with
access or by direct request of relevant
level 4 personnel in the event of
hostile SCP 1836 activity the staff
shaman and cosmetologist are to enter
SCP 1836 using the causeway and enact
the helping hands protocol in the event
of failure foundation personnel are to
fall back and observe ACP 1836 until
enters its inactive state at which time
they are to mobilize mobile task force
89 e Thomas tugga's to toe SCP 1836 back
to site 641 ok we've got two updates
here the dates of these are redacted but
the first one says the helping hands
protocol has been found to have variable
effectiveness to date the protocol has
failed on several occasions to
completely quell SCP 1836 outbursts have
occurred causing three fatalities and
twelve injuries necessitating refilling
of key staff positions in order to
maintain containment the on-site shaman
has been given wide discretion in regard
to the appropriate ritualistic tact to
take when SCP 1836 becomes hostile
additional resources have been made
available to facilitate containment and
the second update reads as follows
following the incidence of the no birds
are allowed to enter proximity with SCP
1836 during the helping hands protocol
all birds roosting on the gravel bar on
SCP 1836 or within a 30 meter radius are
to be chased off or exterminated birds
exterminated in this way will be handed
over to the on-site shaman for
appropriate ritualistic disposal
okay just a little addendum of my own
here in the description of this object
there are a lot of words that I struggle
pronouncing I would just like to
apologize in advance
I have rehearsed today's lecture quite a
bit but I still probably will struggle a
little I just thought it fair to warn
you you can read along anyway you could
see the word
if anybody can correct me I would very
much appreciate it
okay moving swiftly on SCP 1836 is a
green non tabular pinnacle iceberg
peeking 90 meters above the surface
approximately 123 metres in length it is
estimated to weigh between a hundred and
fifty thousand and one hundred and
seventy five thousand metric tons and
extends approximately 450 meters below
the surface submersible surveys of the
SCP 18:36 have revealed many large
tunnels extending into the object aside
from coloration the object appears to be
an ordinary Augsburg call samples have
revealed that the iceberg is composed of
ordinary ice algae and trapped within
the ice give the object its unusual
coloration SCP 1836 - one is a pod of
mammalian organisms of the order citta
see that are housed with NSC p18
thirty-seventh species with fluctuating
composition and number the cause of
these changes in the pod composition are
unknown today the pod has included
specimens tentatively identified as
members of the bacillus aurora day
and below Saturday a cure if I setter
and you Rhino Delfina day recently the
poet's vex Sinha fir has been cited
during a CP 1836 activity the mechanism
by which interspecies communication is
facilitated between pod members is
currently under investigation the
anomalous properties of the object
manifests when marine mammals are hunted
at sea or on the shoreline by any people
who are not off alert you click or
Inupiat ethnicity within a 50 kilometer
radius of the object SCP 1836 will begin
to accelerate toward the hunt until the
object reaches a speed of 35 knots at
this point the hunted mammal or mammals
now designated SCP 18:36 - - will change
bearing to head directly toward SCP
18:36
if underwater topography makes this
impossible SCP 1836 - - will adopt the
most efficient course to bring it within
proximity of scp-1850 6 if 1836 - 2
reaches SCP 18:36 before being overtaken
SCP 1836 - - will place the object
between itself and the hunters as SCP
1836 is strictly ocean-going it could
take no further action against land
bound hunters if the hunter or hunters
continue pursuing SCP 1836 - - in an
ocean-going vessel
however SCP 1836 will proceed to ram the
hunting vessel until it breaches the
hull it will then extrude part of itself
into the hull breach and expand widening
the breach the processes will continue
until the vessel becomes structurally
unsound or begins to sink at which point
the extension will attract if no marine
mammals were killed or injured during
the hunt SCP 1836 will dislodge from the
vessel at this point and drift away
ceasing activity if any marine mammals
were killed
or injured during the hunt however 1836
will remain in close proximity to the
sinking vessel when the hunters evacuate
the sinking vessel between five and
thirty instances of scp-1850 six - one
will emerge from the submerged portions
of scp-1863-a min - the submerged
caverns within scp-1863-a investigation
I can see at the end here expeditions
into SCP 1836 are pending approval
apparently that means they're not
pending approval we have a little update
again here and it reads after a brief
expedition into the interior of scp-1933
know was discovered within the walls of
this chamber is a frozen well-preserved
corpse of a young woman of a new pianist
Nyssa T the corpse had suffered injuries
in the past and is missing its hands at
the wrists only the head of the corpse
is exposed to open air due to safety
concerns only the on-site shaman and
cosmetologist are to have access to this
chamber addendum this is
agents count full brush interviewing
Terri ak the chatelier's on-site shaman
forward following hostile activity - CP
1836 on Terri ak the chatelier's was
called to begin the helping hand
protocol after 80 minutes had elapsed
SCP 1836 ceased activity analyst
chatelier's emerged from SCP 1836 with
injuries reminiscent of prolonged
exposure to the elements and several
bite marks consistent with human and
dolphin jaw architecture on his
extremities he provided the following
debriefing - agent full brush after
receiving full medical attention
all right we're recording let's begin
for the record a two full brush
debriefing tea rock the Shadley air it's
Ciroc we've known each other for a year
now I'm sorry yes it's fine day after
yesterday she's just a little mad at me
is all I'm terrible with a cold and I
thought too hard and she knitted me a
bit it's early can you elaborate sure
every once in a while the ivory comb
gets stuck after I've burned the incense
doctor what's it worth well I don't know
how her hair manages to get so impacted
on stock like when I comb her hair
inside that frozen living room of hers
sometimes it comes to an odd it's got
you comb your own hair or brush it works
like that
if I don't do hard on my own that's no
big deal
I talk on her hair and sometimes I could
knit because let's face it I don't know
what to do with that much hair and she
says sensitively how do you normally
cope with SCPA 1836 when it reacts that
way to your ritual sometimes I sit back
and wait her out sometimes I have to see
a little something burn burn incense
shop or sled dog sometimes she just
wants me to leave I think that I'm
coming as a man at the warehouse is
disconcerting usually when you placate
her you're supposed to look like a fish
or send a fish with a comb in your stead
right is there anything the foundation
could do to improve your ability to
control ICP 1836 no there is nothing you
can do to improve control but you people
just don't like listening to that to
help me out preferably one who knows how
to deal with long ladies hair oh my
hands with pre ritual preparations every
one of her opposites is the same she's
got feelings even if she's willing to
tell you Cala not because you can be
bothered to learn how so formally you'd
like to request an assistant with
haircare experience and greater
operational latitude yes that sounds
about right
the paperwork we'll see what happens
okay everyone there is another incident
report but level 3 authorization only
better luck next year thank you very
much for listening everyone goodbye
[Music]